[Music]
Master director Ridley Scott shares the
first details about Denzel Washington's
role in Gladiator 2 and plenty of other
things have been happening in Hollywood
as well whether it's superheroes science
fiction animated adventures or the next
anime film adaptation you can find all
the latest developments right here in
the Koch
news finally there are some details
about Denzel Washington's role in
Gladiator 2 director Ridley Scott is
currently celebrating box office success
with Napoleon and is now opening up
about the sequel to his classic 24 years
after Gladiator with Russell Crow and
Wen Phoenix part two is to be released
this time Oscar nominated Paul mcal
takes on the starring role of Lucius the
Foster son of Wen Phoenix's character in
the predecessor he meets Denzel
Washington who plays a businessman
Ridley Scott describes the role in an
interview with deadline as follows a man
who supplied the Romans with weapons oil
horses and wine everything they need
needed but he also had a dark past as a
gladiator who was captured in North
Africa and eventually fought his way to
Freedom as a gladiator he uses these
experiences to now run a stable of
Gladiators himself the character of
Denzel Washington is more powerful than
some senators in Rome although he tries
to hide it but his thirst for power is
far from being satisfied in addition to
Paul mascal and denel Washington the
cast of Gladiator 2 is quite impressive
the Mandalorian and the last of a star
Pedro Pascal is also part of the team
and as is moonnight actress May Cami in
a further leading role Fred hinger will
play the young Emperor geta as the
villain from the previous Gladiator
Connie Nielsen and jaman hansu returned
to their roles the movie is set around
15 years after part 1 We are looking
forward to the theatrical release of
Gladiator 2 on November 22nd
2024 news from the world of alien fans
of the horror classic are likely to get
plenty of entertainment in the next few
years as alongside a new movie A series
is also being planned for which
Justified star Timothy olifant has now
been cast as deadline reports olifant is
to play one of the leading roles in the
upcoming Alien series early rumors
suggest that his character will be a
synthetic Android named kersch who will
act as a mentor to the character Wendy
played by Sydney Chandler she in turn is
a metahuman who is in the body of an
adult but possesses the mind and
knowledge of a child no further details
are known about the plot of the series
but it is supposed to be set decades
before the first alien film in addition
to Sydney Chandler and Timothy olifant
several other cast members are already
known among them are Essie Davis known
from the Miss fer films and kit young
who plays one of the many parts in the
popular Netflix series Shadow and Bone a
lot has also happened regarding the Fede
Alvarez directed movie with the working
title alien Romulus in an interview with
variety lead actress Kaylee spany
announced that the latest installment
will be set between alien and the second
part Aliens the movie Alien Romulus
opens in theater on October 16th
2024 sadly it is not yet known when we
will be able to enjoy the still Untitled
Alien
series the first official images of the
Fallout series have finally been
published Vanity Fair shows the first
impressions of the eagerly awaited game
adaptation and one thing becomes clear
the look has fortunately been based
heavily on the games The Story begins in
the year 2296 which is 219 years after a
devastating nuclear war has turned the
US a into a nuclear Wasteland Lucy
played by Ella Pernell hardly knows
anything about it she has spent the rest
of her life in an underground bunker at
her side is her father and overseer Hank
played by Kyle mclin sooner or later
however Lucy has to come to the outside
world for a rescue mission and finds a
world full of mutants and other bizarre
characters in the images we see for
example the Brotherhood of Steel with
their power armor and mighty airships
one of their members is the Squire
Maximus played by Aaron Morton who was
another main character in the story
hardly recognizable is the hateful
eight- star Walton Goggins who plays a
disfigured ghoul who seems to have
stepped straight out of a western
according to the makers he is supposed
to be the opposite of Lucy a tragic
character who has already seen
everything in life Lucy who has grownup
sheltered is soon confronted with a
number of harsh realities that put her
honorable moral values to the test
Jonathan Nolan and his wife Lisa Joy are
in charge of the hopefully convincing
Story the brother of star director
Christopher Nolan has already co-written
movie such as the prestige The Dark
Knight and Interstellar the couple were
also behind the series Westworld for
Fallout they worked closely with
Bethesda the creators of the game
therefore despite all of the
psychological profundity and apocalyptic
mood the well-known black humor will not
be neglected chances are good that the
first teaser trailer for The Fallout
series will be released very soon as
always you'll be able to find it here
first the series will be released on
Amazon Prime video on April 12th
the surge in anime film adaptations
doesn't cease after the extremely
successful adaptation of One Piece the
next project is now in the pipeline an
adaptation of Naruto as a liveaction
movie the anime series revolves around
an aspiring ninja who desperately wants
to become the leader of his own village
together with its sequel Naruto shipin
it consists of over 700 episodes making
it one of the most successful and
popular animes of all time in addition
to the series there are also several
films FMS games and manga that are based
on the world of Naruto this is Recon
enough to devote oneself to the story by
making a liveaction adaptation as
variety reports this is exactly what is
now set to happen through publisher
Lionsgate the movie will be written by
Tasha H who will also be responsible for
the upcoming Tomb Raider animated series
on Netflix haa is excited to bring
Naruto to the big screen in a new way as
a fan she is greatly inspired by the
characters and is thrilled to be able to
tell part of their Journey a screen
adaptation was already planned back in
2015 but the creator of Naro remained
skeptical at the time in his opinion
Hollywood adaptations simply wouldn't do
it right however the success of one
piece is likely to have shown that
things can be done differently now of
course the speculation begins what will
the cast of the Naruto movie look like
and who will play the main character
Naruto Uzumaki will keep you posted on
the latest
develops Sonic 3 is back with a first
image confirming all the previous
assumptions about the the appearance of
a very popular character from the
franchise black fur gloves and shoes in
black white and gold it's Shadow the
Hedgehog of course the director of Sonic
3 and the previous movies shared the
image on social media and pointed to the
movie's theatrical release at the end of
2024 in fact it has long been clear to
many that shadow would play an integral
part in the new Sonic installment even
if there had been no official
confirmation until now he already made
an appearance in the post credit scenes
of part two and is an important
character character in the Sonic
Universe Shadow is an artificial life
form with a deep hatred for Humanity he
will presumably be Sonic's main
antagonist in the new movie which will
most likely have to do without Jim
Carrey as Dr Robotnik after all he has
announced his retirement as an actor
Sonic the Hedgehog 3 will hit theaters
on December 20th
2024 Amazon is working on another
spin-off of the boys it is set to be in
Mexico City although exact story details
are still kept secret apparently the
script for the new boy series is to be
written by Gareth dunnett El koser he
last wrote the DC movie Blue Beetle the
production is backed by the same names
as the boys in the spin-off series genv
together with the animated version the
boys diabolical this would be the fourth
Project based on the comics by gar Denis
and Derrik Robertson while the boy
season 4 will presumably be released in
the second half of 2024 and genv season
2 has at least been announced no further
information is known about the new
spin-off according to variety how
however the project fits in with
Amazon's strategy of creating spin-offs
of successful Series in very specific
settings around the world supposedly to
appeal to new Target audiences let's
hope this business move is not more
important to them than the quality of
the series we are eager to find out how
the boys Mexico will perform in
comparison to its
predecessors good news for all Marvel
fans Avengers 5 the Kang Dynasty is
getting Michael Waldren as a new writer
who will as well be in charge of
Avengers 6 Secret Wars Michael Waldren
has already worked as a writer for
projects including Loki and Doctor
Strange 2 and is certainly the ideal
Choice when it comes to the Multiverse
according to deadline the author will
make sure that Avengers 5 the Kang
Dynasty and Avengers 6 Secret Wars tells
a cohesive story that feels seamlessly
connected since the fifth Avengers part
is still called the Kang Dynasty the
question remains as to whether Disney
wants to stick with the character and
actor Jonathan major after all in
addition rumors are increasing that
after Doctor Strange 2 Sam Ry will
return to the MCU and could direct
Avengers 5 the director's position is
currently vacant as shanqi director
Destin Daniel cron left the project to
devote his time to Shang Chi 2 however
ry's involvement is not the only rumor
currently making the rounds in the
Marvel world according to Hollywood
Insider Daniel Rickman Thor 5 is set to
take on a much darker theme following
the departure of Tao ITI this is to be
ured by the Creator director Gareth
Edwards fans are excited about this
rumor as they already criticized the
strong humoristic approach of the last
two Thor movies while there is still no
release dates for Thor 5 or shangqi 2
the next Avengers films are still
scheduled for May 1st 2026 and May 7th
2027 to conclude we highly recommend
checking out our Sonic the Hedgehog 3
movie preview that we uploaded to our
Channel last week so that you can stay
up to date with all things Sonic we hope
you enjoyed today's news thanks for
watching and as always see you next week
for more Koch news
[Music]